[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link
and i'm red this week at the round table
of dim lighting we're going to be
talking about
some stuff that is making us laugh
right now and i'll expand that
to what makes us laugh
and what doesn't make us laugh i think
that i'm
i've been trying to figure that out as
i've you know pulled together some
thoughts about this
and i'm i'm we've talked about it
between the two of us in the past
just trying to figure out what it is
that tickles our
funny bones and and what the type of
things we avoid
and i just wonder if there's some
conclusions to draw from that well
and i think i don't know it's always
i always find it interesting i'm putting
myself in the
uh your shoes listening i always find it
interesting to listen to people who do
a particular thing for a living like i
guess one way you could distill
what we do for a living is we make
people laugh
that you know hopefully that's one of
the main things that we're doing is
we're trying
i think we eliminate other left emotions
and reactions
along the way but scratch their heads
that's the main
that's the main outcome but i find it
interesting
when people who do something for a
living
uh are then sort of talk about
how they perceive those things in
society and how they
enjoy the thing that they provide the
service that they provide
it's almost like you got somebody who's
like
yeah you know tom you know tom thomas
burgers
he makes a good burger but do you know
where he actually really loves to eat
oh yeah what what kind of a part what
type of burger does tom like to eat does
tom
like to eat his burgers more than he
likes to eat
judy's burgers and this is not a
euphemism get your minds out of there i
thought
todd that isn't there and there's a time
number two
that's something that happens in la is
that there's actually a lot there you'll
have a restaurant
there's a tommy's well tommy is a chain
tommy's is a chain that does burgers and
like mexican food
it's been around for a long time but
there's some other places that are not
quite chains
they're just big enough to have numbers
like there's chinese restaurants and
some burger taco restaurants around la
that are like
i've seen you know from a chinese
restaurant i've seen probably up to
number
maybe number four you know there's
frontier walk
and then there's frontier walk two i
think when you get to number five is
when you
start just saying you know what we don't
have the number of these anymore but
yeah i know what you're saying
i you know it's like i want to ask my
mailman you know how do you feel when
you get mail
do you get i mean does amazon come to
your house how do you feel about that
does a male person
deliver their own deliver their own mail
or is that against the law
you know that office also sounds like
don't [ __ ] where you eat man don't
deliver your own mail don't get caught
delivering your own mail this is kind of
getting back to our sorting the mail
you want to sort the mail oh well you're
going to want to hold on to that a
little you want to sort the mail you've
given something like that for you
with someone else you can sort the mail
yourself
there's nothing there's no shame in that
we were raised to think that there was
shame in sorting your own mail there's
no shame in it it's one of the most
natural things
this is well you know delivering your
own mail that's crossing the line
okay we're going here i have i have
something for you and it's kind of crazy
that you're already on this track that
i'm on mail
well okay so just just put a pause to
that just clear your mind
i'm not going to try to make a segue
because that will there's something i
want to share with you that's not
related to what makes us laugh but i
wanted to go ahead and
you know put it at the top of the
episode um and i could make a grand
segway but instead i'd rather just kind
of
tablerosa clear the slate no tabla rosa
um somebody's been watching a
documentary
what on a latin
latin and philosophy i didn't take a
latin class no i didn't
i've been watching documentaries right
no i know what the term tableau that's
just part of my vocabulary man
you did pay attention in vocabulary you
did very well in vocabulary i remember
thinking about how well you were doing
your vocabulary you either know it or
you don't i was like link's really into
these vocabulary books that miss
who would have given those to us that we
class we would have been in
they were smaller than the other
textbooks it was a it was a smaller book
it was the ag
vocabulary book so if you were
academically gifted you got a you got an
additional vocabulary book and it had
like bigger words in it
right and you were kind of and i took
pride in that
but listen that's not what i want to
talk about i want to talk about
it's been a while since valentine's day
but christy got me something for
valentine's day and i
i keep meaning to bring it in and show
it to you and i have it with me now
and you know there's no pressure for you
to immediately know what this thing is
in fact i hope you don't immediately
watch a lot of documentaries i know a
lot of things
when she gave it to me um there was a
there was a process of discovery
that i had to go through to appreciate
what this was and how to incorporate it
into my personal life
she bought one for herself and she
bought one for me
i have the one that she bought for me in
my pocket
right now and i want it so small i'm
going to give it to you
and i just kind of want i'm kind of
hoping that you can have a similar
experience than the one i had when i
opened
christy's valentine gift for me this is
the only thing she got you it's the only
thing i'm willing to share
oh okay all right then you may think if
he's willing to share this
what is he hiding um okay all right so
do you maybe close your eyes and i you
know i want to recognize that
for the you know for the video version
you're going to get to see this but
we'll try to paint the best picture
possible for
just you audio guys close and i'll get
my hand out
okay
let me balance it a little bit on your
palm
what kind of cup it yeah
there you go this is
i can't get it to stand up okay
there it is that that is my valentine's
gift from my wife maybe
maybe you should just start off by
describing it for our
listeners only is the stand part of it
that's the stand
so you could just put the standard oily
and wet
okay because i've used it all right it
looks like uh it has the
the shape of a of a micro
like one side looks like a microphone
like it's like a
circular it's got a circular head on it
uh
but then it has sort of a handle that if
i just did this
i mean i can't i there's only one thing
that i
know what's it made out of it's made out
of silicone like rubber
or silicon depending on who you are now
you talk about
um push the button well i'm sure it's
gonna vibrate
yeah i'll hold that up to the mic let's
get some
um it's a vibrator uh but
it vibrates but that does i'm just
saying that in a technical term push to
push it again
more intense and then it's got yeah this
is a this is a typical vibrator and then
it's got different speeds and then
pulsing there's a pulse setting then
there's a fast pulsate
yes and then it goes off and there's
four speeds and you can put it in this
you can put it in that stand and it'll
sit up right for you and stare at you
when you're not using it now it's got a
neck it's got a
it's got a round head on it and it's got
an
it's got a it's got a neck that can be
positioned that bends
now don't don't be don't be too rough
with it
oily on the bottom because i've been
using it
um so yeah it it
it vibrates uh christie's is pink and
mine is
okay well i'll say a couple of things if
you were to uh
i'm sure yeah i'm sh
yeah yeah i'm sure it can be used uh
if you were if you wanted to sort your
own mail you could do it
with this but i'm very
convinced that there's so many better
options for that i mean
the fact that it's got these little
nodules on it
from a scientific standpoint i would say
that this is um
there's a hair on it which is a clue
okay you can sure pick those off
is it an exfoliation device it's a it is
a facial cleanser
pmd is the brand she wouldn't tell me
how much she paid for this thing i think
it was over a hundred dollars
and that's a rip-off basically for what
i'm trying to tell you is for
valentine's day
christy gave me a vibrator to rub on my
face
right a facebook vibrator a facebook
i mean i've never had a gift like that
before
um and and sometimes we'll do it in sync
like well over our sinks so at the same
time
tandem the idea is that this is better
than your hands because it's gonna
exfoliate
or you know shake dead skin loose i've
got a manual
face brush that i use in the uh well
in the shower but but but exfoliating
but what is that
she's saying this is better well i'll
tell you why she thinks it's better
because i'm not getting guaranteed
instagram marketing no here it has
nothing to do with the world it has
everything to do with you link neil in
particular and what it's like to know
you and the experience with you now
what is the brush in the shower made out
of
bristles okay i bought it myself
right there is i have zero doubt i would
bet
every dime i've ever seen or will ever
see
that you brush your face too
aggressively with this brush
i thought you were going to say that
bacteria grew on it which is also true
they say that this thing is like anti
that's not interior i'm just saying that
christy has probably
observed you brushing your face with
that brush and she's worried as she
should be because
whenever you get to cleaning or touching
or basically
everything that you decide to do you do
very aggressively you're saying i don't
exfoliate i
max foliate yeah i'm saying that your
exfoliation is clearly
definitely without a doubt too
aggressive i mean the first thing you
got told by your dentist that you were
brushing your teeth too hard the first
thing i did notice
was that because you grabbed this bottom
bulb and there's the little
little skinny that gives it has a give
to it and i was thinking this is not
i got enough scrubbing exactly it does
though because you don't have this is
not what i want to talk about you don't
have to i agree with this
okay listen your wife's safe but your
face the reason why she got that she got
one for herself too the reason why
is marketing it's just a it's an
anti-aging
and vibrate face vibrator
because you know they say things like oh
it gives you it exfoliate
exfoliates it doesn't scrub too hard
it's anti-bacterial
but basically it's just to put something
on your face
and just like it it's supposed to be
more of a deep cleaning
well we're in the age of vibration
everything vibrates now we're in the age
of vibration your toothbrush vibrates
your face brush vibrates and let me tell
you my
my one thing that actually needs to
vibrate well
what of actual vibrator
because that doesn't vibrate i don't
know i was that can be a problem
when i got this and for the first couple
weeks i was totally prepared to just
come in here and make fun of it which
i've done to this point but now i'm
gonna add a little something which is
i might start liking it um
i really you know my battery went dead
in my toothbrush you know
quip is a sponsor not currently a
sponsor i don't think but
um they'll come back so be it i'm i'm
i'm on board with the quip when the
battery ran out i was like
brushing manually and i really felt like
it wasn't doing the job
is that why your dentist was like you're
brushing too hard you're like well my
toothbrush stopped vibrating
i i think it had to make up for it my my
my teeth have improved from that point
but
it is a bit strange to just rub a
vibrator all over your face but i just
wanted you to know that every night
i'm doing that and if you think about me
that's what i want you to picture well
i'm not going to
be thinking about that have you rubbed
have you have you put it anywhere else
no that's what would be a problem with
me i also think that this is kind of a
back
door you know for someone who
is associating some stigma with
self-pleasure
and hey we want to remove any stigma
we can with self-pleasure which is the
thing that you were talking about before
i even brought this thing out of my
pocket
right by the way you can keep it in your
pocket very discreet i'm talking about
i talk about self-pleasure like at least
once a day i just usually doesn't happen
on this podcast i'm gonna be
like whenever i start traveling and
stuff you'll see me in airport bathrooms
using this vibrator on my face but you
have to know how you see you have to use
it with
soap right yeah i put a little dollop of
uh
face stuff there it's an anti-aging
thing that's supposed to make you look
more youthful and and you know that's
just no there's no
marketing is irresistible you know i've
been uh
i've been exfoliating for the past two
years and having never done it before
but it's it's not with it doesn't
vibrate it's just a thing i just it's
just a
thing i scrub on my face with my hands
you know what i'm saying uh what else i
mean i move my hands very quickly when i
do it i'm trying to figure out like my
the seat in my car will vibrate
um trying to there's there's got to be
something that doesn't currently vibrate
that we can
vibratize and just just revolutionize a
market
everybody's just uh vibrating and
vibrating shirt
and these oh just a shirt it's kind of
like the shirts that make your dogs feel
comforted the the tight shirts yes
it's a vibrating shirt a tight vibrating
shirt
i think you can vibrate too much though
that's getting close to still
massage of places that you would massage
like
if the shirt's really tight even if you
just can't if you inflate it a little
bit to make it really tight
and then the massage kicks in i'm sure
people have thought of that
i'm thinking of something else i think a
vibrating comb
like a vibrating bed is something that's
been in uh motels for
you know decades so i'm vibrating
vibrating comb so
i you know because i've got this wavy
hair that gets i mean literally i cannot
if you and you know if you've got hair
like mine or anything curlier
you can't just take a comb and just comb
the hair you just
the hair is the structure of the hair
you can't run a comb through my hair
and so without pulling a bunch of it out
so the only way i can comb my hair and
i've never had to comb my hair because
it's never been this long
is with a vibrator it's one of those wet
brushes so i literally the only time i
comb my hair
is in the shower while there's
conditioner in my hair
all the conditioner my hair and i work
all the knots
out of my hair and by the way i pull so
much hair out like
like enough hair to sew to the hair club
for men to make a hair for a bald man
oh like every time it's scary isn't it
and i only do that like
twice a week because it takes so long i
don't have time
but if you've got hair if that would you
know this is waterproof
you make that brush vibrate and it's
going to work
it's going to work its way through you
know what i bet you you could look on
amazon right
at least vibrating brush is probably
already a thing if not
let's file a pattern right now vibrating
pillow
might get old i mean you definitely
can't read a book or your phone
like with your head resting on a
vibrating surface vibrating
pen so you look like a nervous writer no
no it vibrates very quickly
very quickly and it and it it makes the
i bet you would make the process of
writing even more enjoyable
maybe increase your stamina and also
make
uh the ink come out even even more
uniform
vibrating pen vibrating underwear well
that exists what
yeah that exists man i can tell you a
lot of things exist i
i go to those websites i talk about adam
and eve
yeah adam and eve and there's other ones
like that
yeah you can get vibrating underwear i
mean basically it's just a pair of
underwear that has a little
vibrator pocket for in there i mean
that's not i mean that's exciting
yeah i'm into it but that that's been
done we're not going to
win any awards for that event america is
not going to give
give johnny a scholarship for that i
remember
there's that website mypleasure.com not
a sponsor that's another one
that's a good one because there's no
pornographic images on that website
so if that's if you don't if you want to
avoid those if that's you if that's not
your cup of tea
then you can you can go there and you
can get your your bedroom toys
and you don't and you you don't have to
worry about
um seeing things that you don't want to
see if you don't if if if that's your
thing that you don't want to see
oh it's also not a sponsor but hey shout
out i think they're still in business
i mean not i mean not having the you
know the real people on the website was
probably hurting the business
but like you said maybe there may be
there there are there are people who
i mean i kind of want to see how it fits
do you know what i'm saying
i kind of want that term i i kind of
want to know like well
how does this actually relate to the
human body you know
how do they yeah yeah how do these
vibrating underwears go on
is it one leg through each hole in the
waistline at the top
but there's nothing let's see i mean
because like your xbox controller
vibrates
you freaking everything vibrates i mean
is there nothing that we can come up
with that we can get excited about
because we
i think the comb is not a bad idea is
not a bad idea we got a musical comb
it probably exists but if it's musical
vibratory well all right we can talk
about that all day
i'm gonna put this back in my pocket
yeah just don't vibrate it while we're
talking please
um we also in my jacket pocket not my
we don't we don't have anything that uh
vibrates in the in the mythical store
but we do have magical
mugs that change color when you put
they're heat activated when you put a
hot beverage in there it creates a scene
mine has related to the good mythical
morning intro it is revealing the scene
but i can tell you right now
it one of the things about this is that
when you put your hot drink your coffee
your tea
in this thing you can get an indication
that it's starting to cool
that you need to get back to it before
it gets tepid
you know i'd rather drink all my coffee
and some some
big gulps while it's still warm then
discover that i've got a third of my
coffee and it's tepid no and this gives
you a visual representation of that so
it's not just that
it is the coolest most magical mug
you've ever seen
but it is also functional and
vibrates and here's one of the things a
lot of people have asked
how is it that on good mythical morning
whoever has the heat activated mug it
just stays hot all the time well
a little inside information secret uh
the one i have
is always activated to give the
appearance that it always has something
hot in it the one that link is currently
using
is an authentic one which is why you see
that the top of his flame is already
fading
look at the top of my flame it will
never fade so yeah it is trickery
and if you're a member of the mythical
society you already knew that because we
answered it in an ama we give all types
of secrets over there
double ad yeah mythicalsociety.com and
mythical.com to get your magical mug
needs
met rep your boys okay
what makes us laugh so my contribution
in this episode is gonna be more
philosophical than like i don't i and i
think our
the list that you have uh i'll i'll have
some camaraderie that because you
actually made a list of things that are
currently making you laugh
right yeah yeah okay i mean some things
that more historically have made me
laugh have made us
laugh that like yeah i'm not yeah my
stuff is not
nothing really maybe except one is
current
but how you want to be how do you want
to get into it at them
um i don't know i could just start with
one
sure so
i kind of was thinking about um
things that reliably make me laugh like
i'll i'll be honest i don't
often make the decision
to be like i specifically
want to laugh right now like that is not
a
i really need a laugh i'm going to go
here yeah i i
that is not a common thing i don't think
like that either and we've talked about
this before on the show that
we typically when we think about if
we're going to commit to a television
show
very rarely will it be a comedy now
there are some some comedies
i absolutely love but my favorite shows
are dramas right that's that's where
those are the things i kind of get lost
in and even from movies
i typically like a drama more than i
like a comedy i don't
just make the choice to be like hey
let's watch this because the primary
intention
is for us to laugh and i don't know
i've heard that from a lot of people who
are comedians that they don't
find their entertainment in comedy as
much as they find it in other things
because they're spending all day
doing things to make people laugh or
thinking about things many people left
so i don't know maybe that has something
to do with it maybe there's an element
of work mode
i think there's also an element of like
really escaping
into a story that you can really invest
in
and put some time into and that level of
escape is
akin to getting a laugh
from something and but i
but i do think i i would like to be a
little more intentional
in not shying away from seeking out
laughter
because it does the body good yeah so
so if you were to go where would you go
first uh well just the other day
you know we were uh here in the office
shooting some stuff and then we had a
lunch break
and sometimes we'll eat lunch and not
have a meeting over lunch
and this was one of those occasions so
we could eat lunch and
just put something on the tv
and uh i brought up
the i think the name of the video is vic
berger
presents the very best of jim baker now
you remember if you watched good
mythical morning a couple years ago
jim baker is the televangelist
who was really popular in the 80s he and
tammy fay
and they also def you know you know they
fraud they were
guilty of fraud and he took a bunch of
money and
he but he had this sort of redemption he
went to prison then he came back and he
is again a televangelist
and i think he's got it he's like set up
in branson missouri he invites these
audiences
into his program he's got a new wife
who's kind of tammy fade-like
wears not as much makeup but she kind of
serves the same role that tammy fay
served for him back in the day and the
thing that he has gotten obsessed with
as many televangelists do is the end
times and so
he's not just talking about the end
times and the apocalypse that's always
impending
he's also selling things that you can
prepare for the end times with
including and survive jim baker buckets
which we taste tested on good mythical
morning you should watch that episode if
you haven't
it's like a big five gallon plastic
paint bucket but it's filled with
food and it yeah on his show which he's
got you know he's got like a morning
show set and he's got
his wife is a co-host and he's got these
other co-hosts and they'll make and
they've got a
studio audience that's that's sitting in
like dinner tape
places mostly yeah and
i mean you'd think you would open a
bucket and it would just
be full of creamed corn or potatoes
because they make it in the buckets
and they stir it as if they're feeding
they present
the most unappetizing fashion
imaginable including having a giant
bucket of rice in which jim baker
reaches his bare hand into and just
eased the rice now let me just say
i could watch any of this jim baker
programming
unedited just as it is and be very
entertained
and i have for i want to be clear about
this
because you guys know our story
you know that we were raised in
conservative christianity
evangelical christianity and we're no
longer a part of that
tradition yeah i don't consider myself a
christian
at this point it feels like maybe we're
coming after
but let me just be very clear when i was
a committed evangelical christian
on staff as a missionary with a
christian organization
i would still watch guys like
kenneth copeland jim baker uh
tbn for entertainment purposes
this again this is a little bit of a
deep cut and it might be for those of
you who don't come from a christian
background you might be like what i
don't understand
so when we were christians we
considered ourselves and i think rightly
so
a totally separate thing from those
televangelists right and most christians
that i know that i'm friends with
that i was friends with that i can
remain friends with through this day my
family everybody
they do not they think that those dudes
are a bunch of whack jobs kooky
so they they just just to their credit
they recognize
that these guys are swindlers these guys
are about getting rich these guys are
about taking advantage of the vulnerable
these guys are about making these empty
promises
at least from the tradition that we come
from so but i always got
such a kick out of it because you can't
deny the entertainment value
that these televangelists bring yeah so
there's no agenda here to like tear some
sort of preacher apart
this is something that i was thinking
about exactly the same way that i think
about now
yeah my entire life just to be clear
but and he has taken advantage of people
and
by you know tapping into fear and
selling buckets of camp food for
thousands of dollars yeah enough trying
to sell enough of it that he's
demonstrating how you can turn the
buckets
into furniture in your home you just put
a table top over them and then a curtain
but vic berger bic
b-e-r-g-e-r to give the other side of
this
i don't really we've never met vic
before i
that might i don't even know if that's
his real name but
we love him he's been associated with
people like tim and eric
and he he was uh super
he was associated with super deluxe
doing some stuff for them for a while
but essentially this guy is the master
of awkward
edits of taking people who are genuinely
already funny
and weird and awkward and then editing
them
in a way that accentuates that
awkwardness
to a complete new level the music and
the edits
and the way that he kind of doubles back
on things and emphasizes things
it's a creative layer
that's editorial in in in a sense that
like he's bringing his point of view to
it and adding another layer but you
never
lose the initial magic you
you can you can watch a vic burger edit
and appreciate the fact that
yes it's manipulated but the but the
things that jim baker and his cohorts
are saying
is not manipulated he really said and
did all these things
and so like you said you could just
watch the show you need a little more
patience
and you got you have to get over the
sadness of them taking advantage of
people
but at a certain point especially with
vic's additions
you can just embrace it as this strange
comedy well i i wanna i'll push back on
that getting over the sadness if i'm
taking advantage of people because
getting over it's not the right word
i'll just say that i think that the
people who are taken in
by people like jim baker i don't have a
lot of sympathy for them well
that's harsh because i mean you you got
like you know you got some blue-haired
grannies
and it's just you know the cert they get
they you got to protect those people
you can't expect them to take advantage
of what but what what harm is being done
to them
money they're i mean drained yeah but
they're i mean
they're getting buckets of food i don't
think that
those i don't think people are going
broke i don't think these old folks are
going broke buying jim baker buckets you
know and i do think that
but they're scared of the end times and
that they're well
i and here's fear-mongering i do think
that and i do have i don't have jim
baker buckets
uh i have a fair amount i have a few
months supply
of freeze-dried food at my house you
know and i got you some
that's probably the only you probably
have like a couple weeks that i gave you
um but the uh it isn't like
selling a blessed and i don't know jim
baker may do this but like
some people will like sell a blessed
you know towel that's got holy water on
it and he's not like healing people
he's not like giving people faults
healing hope and stuff like that maybe
he did that back in the day
all i'm saying is i don't feel that bad
about that part of it because
the worst thing that's happening is some
old folks are getting
more freeze-dried food than they
actually will use they're going to die
and this stuff is going to be on their
shelves and get handed down to the next
generation
so listen but the one thing we can agree
on is that even though i feel more
i feel bad about it more so than you i
feel sorry for
these people it's so funny that you can
still get over it
i can still get over it and we can agree
on that how funny it is
i mean it's it's it's taking this
reality
and it's adding this it's just creepy
juxtapositions and
you got to watch it and there and
there's and
i'm sure you're going to this is one of
the things you're going to talk about uh
no actor here i'm not
interested in in an actor
portraying a jim baker character that's
i mean now
now sure i would laugh at it like you
okay
i would pay up i'd pay a ticket price to
watch sam rockwell and a jared hess
yeah well okay i'm a fan of that already
i'm a fan of the righteous
gemstones the hbo show which is which is
different but you know
i'm a fan of that it's kind of making
fun of uh
kind of televangelist mega church
culture in the south but it's a totally
different thing when you know
this is a dramatization but i would much
rather
see the real thing and i'm sure that if
i'm sure that first of all i know that
jim baker
and his wife uh and the other people
associated with especially some of the
younger people who are some of my
favorite people to watch are the younger
people who are associated with it like
on stage
yeah i know that they know about the vic
burger edits
and you know that they're mad about them
because they think that it's
misrepresents them and like you're
saying not really though
it's like he's taking all the things
that you said and you did
and he's putting them together and yes
he's manipulating the edit and if this
was a
if this was in the court of law this
would not be admissible evidence but
it's you were laughing at the things
that actually happened because
that's the position yeah yeah we have
this shared fascination with
like people being real i mean
you know that as a family we are
dedicate we've dedicated our lives to
watching survivor
that is like our life it's a funny show
on television
but you know what one of the things that
i love about it is that
when you get some really good characters
which is basically just
people who are unabashedly strange
and they can't they can't hide it you
know out there on the island
you're you know you your soul is bared
your your personality is
like all of your defense mechanisms
everything you do it's just
i love the psychological analysis
of that and some people are really funny
and
they do a good job an emmy-winning job
of editing these characters
and especially because they're put in
situations
that aren't romantic that's actually
you know there's so much of that out
there that's that's why i love survivor
is that you're seeing real people
sometimes really strange people
being pushed to their limits and it's
not about
making out with somebody now that i know
that that's
that's also entertaining for you and you
really get into it but
well well i i'm not into
uh 90 day fiance because of the making
out trust me i
i'm or or the bachelor it's for the
it's just it's for the putting
normal people in a situation
in an abnormal situation really it's the
same it's
for me it's the same principle i also
enjoy i enjoy
survivor we don't watch it religiously
but yeah
it's not a comedy but yeah i but
i enjoy the trashy reality shows more
because
the people are more
extreme like that's the thing jim baker
like i
i have complicated feelings towards jim
baker because
he creeps me out in a certain way but at
the same time
something about the way his his eyes
move and his
the mouth the position that he has and
the way that he expresses things
is incredibly endearing these are things
that
just happen on his face yeah he hasn't
you can tell that he hasn't watched
himself back and book
and and become a persona like a lot of
i think televangelists i think they do
that there's a performance as
i mean of course he's a performer too
he's a host he's you know he's been on
television but he's not
polished or slipped but he's not yeah
but so much of is still instinctive like
why is his face doing that right now
right and if he if he was your granddad
you would it's a granddad
you would find all those weird things
like his fashion sense like the fact
that he
like he's got that hat with the cross on
it and then he's got these
vests that he'll wear that look like
he's going fly fishing but he's not he's
just hosting a show
yeah these little choices a lot of empty
pockets
i just i find it intoxicating
you know what i'm saying it's great and
and that and
and the process of someone trying to be
funny and
again this goes back to why when we made
the local commercials
we were so into it because you take
somebody like
gorgon you know from the shift that
shifted commercial
and the entertainment quality for us
was based in getting gorgon to make a
commercial
you know what i'm saying well it was
also very imp
what do you mean well it was very
important that we that we preserve and
platform the strangest parts of
our clients that were actually real well
but also we didn't manufacture a
personality like the scene
where he is answering the phone but he
he hesitated
and he yeah we didn't fully direct him
when you when you want to get these type
of performances out of people you direct
them enough
to push them in a direction to see what
they would do but then you let them
direct themselves
so it was like he i can't remember i
think he picks up the phone
and says says something and he no he's
on the phone and he sees the woman drive
up oh yeah but he didn't know
if he should keep the phone up or put it
down and there's a hesitation
yeah and it's like we see that kind of
thing and we're like that's the gold
that's what we want there's i don't know
and i can't really
express i can't articulate what it is
but for me
there's this this yeah relatable honesty
in that moment of he's like i don't know
what to do with the phone
and we're like well that's why this is
going in the commercial and it kind of
worked
from a story standpoint too that like i
know he sees this beautiful woman
who uh you know just responded to a
craigslist ad
to show up and be in his commercial um
but like oh you know he's he's
bum-fuzzled
on a couple of that's what it seems like
from a character standpoint he's doing
but you know at the same time that as
he's not an actor and he's doing this i
mean i know you want to talk about
family feud right
there's a connection to that um yeah so
another thing that i'll do
is watch compilations
of family feud yeah we've done this for
years
but more recently
i've been watching just whole episodes
of the family feud
now is it as good as the compilations
it's not as concentrated by any means
but sure you actually get into the the
gameplay
and my family and i will sit down you
guys are watching survivor the
mclaughlins are watching family feud
and being like committed to the gameplay
like
really everyone's trying to answer
everybody's like saying
uh saying the answer and we're getting
into it and then i find myself doing the
same thing so
one of the classic things in family feud
is after the round has been completed
and there's still some unanswered
unrevealed answers on the board
they'll be like they reveal them and
then the crowd just
reads out cultivably repeats it yeah you
know it's like we asked 100 people
what's the first thing you put on in the
morning
underwear like everybody says that and i
find myself
watching it and saying underwear
you you speak out loud yes i am
i am a committed audience member and
then i'm like okay what is
okay what is steve gonna do st steve's
gonna
he's okay oh he's all over this one
they're gonna say this this
he's gonna make fun of this guy oh he's
gonna pull back a little bit because
this girl's not responding that well to
this
and also the producers making the
decision
the whole system of family feud is now
designed to create youtube clips
so it's gotten way more suggestive they
because it used to be accidentally
suggestive and then they were just like
let's just go all the way and let's just
ask questions sometimes i go a little
too far embarrassing and it seems too
forced but again it's also
i'm fascinated by these people playing
this game
have never been on television and the
i'm thinking about what is going through
this
like this dad brings his family and he's
thinking 17
things he's thinking i'm on television i
don't want to be an
idiot i might end up being on youtube i
want to win the money
i want to beat that other family i got
to think about the actual way that
people would have answered this
yeah and i'm fascinated by the honest
human psychology of somebody being on a
game show yeah
once you and it is it's a brilliant
setup because once you have
all of that going through your mind and
then steve harvey's in your face asking
you a question
this that surreal experience i'm there
now
then you you you
you can't manufacture responses you end
up just saying the first thing that
comes to your mind
you know you're playing the game but
like you're playing it in this kind of
weakened
laid bare state where it's like you
can't
you you know there's the self
preservation
you know that quotient has has gone to
nil by by this point
yeah and it and it's the perfect recipe
for people to embarrass themselves
with honesty yeah honesty i think that's
that's great that's what we go back to
and you've got somebody
uh steve harvey the reason that he's
such a good host
is because he's
incredibly honest so like you can't say
something that's a dumb answer yeah and
not have him point it out
and not have him drag you yeah and some
people might be like well that's kind of
unfair it's like you know what you're
getting into
you know chill out a little bit you know
what you're getting into when you go on
that show
and the thing is is that
in the same you know how you and i are
we make observations about people we've
talked about this many times where we'll
go to a party whatever we have an
interaction with somebody and there'll
be
something specific about a person just
something notable about them
and then we'll get into the car go home
and be like hey when we talk to that guy
what would you
what did you notice about him and then
we'll be like we have fun
figuring out what was it that you
noticed about him it was his jacket
or it was the way he pointed at somebody
when he was talking to them
yeah you know what some specific thing
we're fascinated by that element of
humanity was he winking
and then was there something in his eye
and steve harvey will
not let you get away with something he
points it out
and then he has he can be funny about it
in the moment that's what makes him good
that's every family feud host has been
able to do that but that
the observational sense of humor does
make me think of seinfeld you know i i
that was our favorite sitcom growing up
um you know it was unlike any sitcom
before
but it was it's taking
you know you could tell when when you
were watching these characters and
everything that happened that
it was larry david and jerry seinfeld
pumping these characters full of their
observational humor
so yeah you're one step remove removed
and that these are
you know these are actors but the
subject matter was still that
observational
honesty and exploring that stuff and
then
you within a character like kramer
or a lot of the characters it was yeah
it was the other characters kind of
picking them apart picking apart
jerry picking apart his dates um
them everyone picking apart elaine's
dates
including elaine you know and
well they they picked apart everybody
that was outside of their circle
which i think is something that maybe we
we enjoyed and then adopted
in in our friendship and sort of picking
it apart but they were all [ __ ]
yeah all of them all four of the main
cast who never
well kramer kramer wasn't no he wasn't
yeah as much
but they were all [ __ ] but
and that's why one of the reasons people
didn't think that it would work because
it's like
who who likes these people and that
might it
also might be one of the reasons that
but i i didn't younger generation
watches it now and is like well first of
all you have to get over the 90s of it
and the laugh track and all that stuff
but it wasn't that i liked them first i
l i understood how they
thought right yeah exactly and then you
start to like them
as people when you start to appreciate
more of it but
you know i was thinking about like what
are the what are the shows i watched now
like
you know i watched ted lasso and i
really liked it
but not necessarily for the comedy but i
mean there were
definitely funny moments i like i like
it for the heart yeah
for the for the heart i think it was you
know i really enjoyed
how the the characters all went on
journeys and i yeah i don't think it was
first and foremost the comedy
that that made me love the show it took
a while to get into it there was like
some hokey situations or whatever but
some of my least favorite parts of ted
lasso are some of the jokes that don't
work
now i think uh i think ted lasso as a
character
oh yeah like he worked i love the show
he was locked in
it was the people around him and the
type of jokes but
you know as as we've talked about the
the things that we like the most like
when i think of television i think of
seinfeld i think of the office and then
when i think of movies
and i try to draw some conclusions from
this like the type of comedy movies that
we like
like the the
adam sandler movies even the will
ferrell movies like
that that type of stuff that was like
over the top
i never i watched some of those but i
never really got into it like
the type of comedies that i really got
into were like the coen brothers
comedies and then trying to figure out
why is it that
i thought the big gabowski was so much
funnier than
well i was going to say talladega nights
but that's a that's a real
date movie i i think that one's an
exception because i also think that will
ferrell
and and adam sandler are very it's a
very different
approach yeah once i began to appreciate
the adam mckay of it all and once he
started to create
so many other oscar-worthy movies
is that like i started to reassess how
how i had written off those will ferrell
movies um
and i do think that they're great but i
think that
the thing that i was drawn to and i
think both of us
and that we've talked about is well we
definitely don't like
like this joke oriented sitcoms we like
more of the situational
oriented sitcoms um and have that
different
um single cam tone versus them the
multi-cam big bang theory
like every word out of their mouth is a
joke and it's everything is just a setup
for them to get to tell more jokes and
realizing that didn't resonate with me
but seeing what was different about the
things that did i think one of the
things that concluded was i mean
having characters that are built funny
that i could you know i think that
there's something to that and what we've
already talked about about
our fascination with the comedy in real
people like a really well-built
comedic character take any character
from the big lebowski i think it applies
and then you put those type of
characters in situations
that are funny and then let them say
what they would say
in those situ and do and respond in
those situations
and that's that's funny that and it will
be funny
i love that and there will be as opposed
to the joke oriented stuff when it's
like all of this is just a setup so
they can say things that are funny yeah
and then it's all about
what do i do did i laugh at that joke or
not and did i laugh at a high enough
percentage of the jokes to think this
movie was good
i think it's when you can sense the
presence of the writer
uh it becomes it's a turn off right for
us
uh yeah yeah so and we we say funny
situations versus
jokes when we first talked about that we
thought it was like a
revelation it seems no but no but i
think the way that you you broke it down
is exactly
right it's it's it's funny people
being put in funny situations and they
will say
memorable funny things but
it's not jokes some now some and
it might have okay so you take some one
of my favorite shows barry
right um barry on hbo
uh bill hader you know plays the uh
basically a hit man who's trying to
become an actor and it has one of our
favorite actors in it steven root
uh and it
is it kind of toes the line right it has
there are some
ridiculous characters that say
things that no one would ever actually
say no matter who they were
you put them in this situation okay this
that was the a writer's idea of what
would be a funny thing to say that was a
joke that was a setup that was a
punchline it happens
uh and and you know what when they go a
little bit too far
i don't like it but i love the show
because
they don't do it very often oh the way
we put it was choices
yeah funny choices versus jokes yes it's
like
so it's kind of like behind the scenes
with
the brilliance of barry is that you take
you put these
you build these characters you put them
in this like high-stakes situation
but you tweak everything for the comedy
everything that it could be i mean this
could be key for sullivan in
in 24. you could have the same
characters in the same story but you
could
the way that all the situations are
turned towards
comedy to kind of skewer the acting
world and acting classes
and just the situations the irony of
somebody
who is a killer trying to become an
actor
yeah um we just can sense this funny
those the choices set up the comedy
not the and then you trust the payoff
versus
writing the joke as a the punch line is
a payoff and in the stuff that we're
currently working on
which we are we continue to develop and
write things that we really hope you'll
see
at some point but that's really what
we're focusing on now
so important the beginning is so
important to us for those reasons
because then you trust that if you set
it up right
that the comedy will take care of itself
and this is not let me just be clear
this is not what we did
on buddy system either see yeah season
one
uh which we always sort of dog a little
bit and say isn't any good
it's not great um it had some jokes in
it
that did that didn't that didn't land we
kind of did the funny situation thing
second season we like better because it
was better executed it was a better
story we were playing characters we
weren't just playing ourselves
but it was absurdist and also it did
have
many things that were said and done were
things that no one would ever say and do
and i think that it worked and i do like
absurdist comedy
and i do i even like sitcoms at times
but none of the stuff that we're
currently working on plays in that world
right now everything that we're working
on is like these characters are
funny this situation that we're putting
them in
is going to draw out the funny because
as they navigate this world or this
serious situation or this perilous
situation
they're going to end up saying and doing
funny things because that's the way the
characters are built
but we're going to try to authentically
represent what we think this character
would
actually do in this situation and that's
that's a big that's kind of a big shift
for us
creatively right because again when you
think about what we do
and sort of like the sketches that we
put out on
uh instagram or tick tock or that kind
of thing it's like
those are it's a completely different
medium it's not it's
your you're the conceit is we're in a
comical ridiculous
non-believable world so i it's a totally
different thing
the stuff that we're working on
narratively like longer form stuff
is in that sort of more authentic place
but let's go to the
to the social media of it all because i
mean
i mean of course my kids only go to tick
tock
and so much of that is comedy you know
and they're like
just sitting there laughing and like
sharing sharing stuff with each other
and i think that the way the reason that
and i'll show and i know you know the
guy that i'm going to talk about
and because you think he's funny as well
i think
the thing uh makes a funny
tick tock for me and again this is
obviously completely scripted because
in the example that we're going to talk
about in the example of many examples
it's like
one person playing every single role so
it's obviously
fake and obviously written it's a
narrative thing
it's the very specific choices that make
it feel like
fresh comedy it makes it feel like
somebody is kind of pushing into
a new sort of boundary and a new way of
thinking about
comedy or there's just something about
this person that is just
intrinsically funny so i'm going to talk
about
pd usa
so p-e-t-e-y
usa long-haired bearded guy he's i mean
he's only
585 000 followers
at the time of this uh recording
and um i don't listen i don't know
anything about this guy all i know is
his tick tocks
and i find his tick tock is very funny
so i'm just gonna let's just
did you see the one about cornhole yeah
i've i've seen a lot of these i really
like them okay well let's just watch the
one about corn and he's playing i mean
he's playing this pd usa is this
character but
something about the fact that you don't
know what you're gonna get when you
scroll across tick-tock you want to
believe that this is a real person
he does such a good job in his portrayal
that
i mean the nature of the comedy is so
strange
that um you know that it's
it's intentional but it's also so
strange that it must have come from a
really strange person so you start to
think that this guy is self-aware enough
to tap
into his strangeness but i think there's
a lot of
the real guy definitely out front here
definitely so
even that trying to parse that is is
fascinating he's not trying to be
somebody who he's not
he's trying to be he's trying to be an
elevated version of himself okay let's
watch this one about cornhole
okay plain corn hole oh a hand comes out
of the corn hole
takes his corn bag it's kind of creepy
oh it's him in the corn hole
cut in half how are you not even
bleeding oh i'm bleeding pretty good
actually
yeah oh he's he's got blood all over the
place i love the fact that
when he says expletives he beefs it out
but you can still hear it
he's making all these choices
now he comes out of the house a third
version of himself
is he bleeding yeah he's bleeding pretty
good what's he doing in the corn hall he
just wanted to do a little just such a
great
strangely normal cup a little goofy yeah
pretty good actually does he want a soda
or anything i got some in the fridge
i'll ask him hey man oh no he's dead
what's up i think he just passed away
passed away
yeah he's passed on unfortunately passed
on
to do that yeah half a guy doesn't tend
to last too long does he
that's it that's it yeah half a guy
doesn't tend to last too long does he
i mean where did who comes up with this
stuff
petey does how does pd come up with this
stuff it's it is
it's brilliant i mean i can see this
if if i met this guy and he was totally
normal i would believe it
i mean the the performance could be that
masterful he could be somewhere in the
middle and there could be a lot of
strangeness in his
in his real persona but i can definitely
see him showing up in movies
it he it has to already be happening
sure he has to be on here
he's going to audition playing this
character let's watch another one
i don't even know which one this is it
just has 3 million views so it must be
good
play okay so he's watching
this guy's swimming he's watching guys
like swim in an olympic pool
with himself then he comes in
you got it man epic hold their breath
they hold their breath
and then they do one of these he's
acting like a swimmer
none of these guys have ever seen
swimmers yeah
yeah they're fascinated by one of these
guys no way
no way five of them it's guys swimming
like fish
well yeah but they're guys incredible
guys screaming like fish swimming like
fish
now they're slapping five with each
other i mean the editing is so great
because
it's just one guy and the music
music is strange
exactly man still giving fives it's like
what
that's it it's just footage of swimmers
it's just they're watching the two guys
swimming
they meaning him playing five different
characters everybody's the same thing
they're all the same different clothes
he's so great and he puts his music this
like
this weird ethereal music
yeah in underneath everything that is
also
a very specific and wonderful choice
it's totally it's just so
fresh i think that's the thing that i i
love about it is that
i can't compare it to any other comedic
sensibility
it's out of left field and it so it
surprises you
and it makes you feel a little envious
like i know that
we i could never you know can never be
that guy well
but i would i'd like to i'd like to have
that ability well i think that yeah
there
we have a tendency um
again i think that the pd is
this is calculated of course he knows
why it's funny he's self-aware
enough to know why he's funny um
but but he's you can tell just like you
said earlier
he if you met this dude the way that he
would interact with you is like
one of these characters i don't know
anymore it it's it no i'm saying is like
i mean that's his haircut he has chosen
to have that long hair
in that way right that's that that's a
choice he could be in a
you know he could be in an allman
brothers cover band right but but
and i think that there is this like yeah
okay well we would have to play
some kind of character in order to
achieve this and at that point
it would this is something this is one
of the things that's happening with
comedy in general right
so there is this in a good way
this new appreciation for authenticity
again
he is playing a character he's coming up
with these situations that
i'm not saying that he would just bond
with some dude over a guy swimming in
that way
it's clearly a joke it's clearly
elevated and it's clearly scripted
but that thing you're talking about is
this authenticity
of it's the same reason that
people are so into commentary videos
right now is because
i'm watching someone honestly process
process something and if they're really
funny and they make really funny
observations about it
they're kind of interacting with it in
the way that i
want to interact with this the best
commentators are the
are the ones that you never get a sense
they're trying too hard that's
absolutely something that we have you
know that
we've had a problem with all along is
just trying too hard pushing too hard
and i you know i think once we've i mean
we're still relaxing into good mythical
morning and i'm encouraged
i think people are picking up on it that
it's
you know we're just we're we're pushing
things
less and less and just saying you know
what we're just going with it
and if and if we do something that where
we are pushing the comedy of something
i think that you can tell
or they can tell that it's it's more
from a place of like we're mo
we're just motivated to want to do it
we're not trying to achieve something or
get something out of somebody
we think it's funny and so we're just
screwing around with each other
i think that level of authenticity is
something after all these years we're
still
we're still working at and still homing
i you know i i know no that would be
honing that is the one
you actually that yeah if you're still
working on it you're still honing it
i'm still working on the use of that
term you can just use honing and also
another well that's what you concluded
before and you just went back on
yourself
it's your fault you get in my head man
i mean the other the other show that i
like the hbo show how to with john
what's his last name yeah uh i'd like to
look it up cameraman
i put it on my list of we're we're
having a creative
uh little meeting later today yeah it's
almost it's on my list
yeah um a favorite shows
look up his freaking last name because
as much as i love the show i hate the
fact that i can't remember i got it i've
got it on my list
yeah it it's so i mean
he films john john how to with john
wilson he films
he's got reams of footage from his life
living around
new york city and then he turns it into
these
he pieces it together as these
narratives
yeah kinda like there's there's stories
that you're following
uh there's ideas that he's exploring and
and there's
lots of left turns so it's not a
beginning middle and end it's a
beginning left turn left turn
look at where we ended up you loved
every second of it but we have a
difference of opinion i think
on just how authentic
uh his he is how much is he the guy
that he is presenting himself and how
much is calculated
i think it's more calculated than you
last time we talked about it at least
i'm on the opposite side of pd usa uh
but
but this is good because this this is
exactly what first of all
i don't care how calculated it is
because the final product is believable
right and that is where how i think that
all this
this move towards authenticity that's
taking place in the creator driven
entertainment system that is tick tock
youtube whatever
it's not going to do away with
larger budget produced scripted content
it just influences it and the way that
it influences it
is the stuff that we're talking about
which is
really good it's why comedians have to
be better actors than they had to be 20
years ago
i think in order to make the kind of
comedy that i want to see and that is
because
you need to be able to get me to buy
into
the authenticity the reality of the
character that you're portraying
and then i can feel free to laugh but
the moment that i feel
like i sense the actor and i sense the
writing
which is something that no one cared
about when chevy chase was doing it in
the 80s
and again you can still go back and
enjoy all those things
legitimately enjoy chevy chase in the
80s i'm not saying it's not funny
but the reason that you can't just do
that now is because anything because
people are viewing all that old stuff
through the lens of nostalgia and you're
appreciating it and you're giving it the
benefit of the doubt because of what it
was
but nowadays i do think the stuff that i
think that
it isn't some grand calculation that
we've made i think that we're responding
to the environment of the comedy that
we're into and is around us and we're
like
this has got to be all it has to feel
authentic that doesn't mean that
somebody's not going to be a character
actor that doesn't mean that somebody's
not going to play a completely different
person it doesn't mean that somebody's
going to be you take christopher guest i
mean one of the reasons that that stuff
holds up for me
we watched best in show all the
mockumentaries we watched best in show
a couple weeks ago me and jesse and
shepard and shepard absolutely loved it
you know you take the character that
christopher gus plays in that movie
which is
obvious the hound dog guy is not him
it's this dude from uh
some place in north carolina but i can't
remember i think it's a made up name
pine tree pine nut north carolina yeah
and but everyone plays those characters
so
authentically what does he list out he
lists out different types of
types of nuts types of nuts you got pine
nuts you got
peanuts you got almond nuts you got
and he loves those dogs yeah but the
reason that he's
funny it's because you can taste because
guess doing this off the top of his head
but he's also tapping into something
that is representative
of something that is real and exists
yeah which is why
talladega nights is kind of like the
outlier
will ferrell movie for me because i knew
how true it was
and it was actually a lot more grounded
than someone who didn't live
you know grow up around where we did
would think that it was just too
ridiculous but
it was actually more grounded truth i
mean it's it's
there's all kinds of theories about what
makes something funny
and and philosophers have been debating
it forever but i always
kind of gravitate towards this idea that
there the truth
that there's truth in comedy and that's
the thing that you're kind of connecting
with
and you can get to truth through things
that are absurd and
completely unreal like we both are huge
fans of the mighty boosh and nothing
that happens in the mighty boosh is it's
almost like you can't you you have to go
to you have to pick a side of the
argument right
you have to be like i'm going to try to
be authentic and represent the truth
in a way that you'll find relatable or
i'm going to be so
far removed from your own understanding
and experience that you'll be
you it's almost there's an uncanny
valley yeah between
like and realists yeah that i just don't
if you're living i love kenny valley i
love rick and morty i mean the absurdist
nature of rick and morty
i mean as an animated show for i guess
as an old fart like me it's like yeah
you have that suspension of disbelief
and like but yeah the mighty boosh did
that
too where it was like you're just gonna
embrace the the crazy
when you talk about the evolution of
comedy it does
end of television i mean it does make me
think of like the brilliance of wanda
vision
and how um i noticed
that i enjoyed the later episodes
better because they were
it was easier to enjoy them because the
form was something that was
closer to more familiar it was more well
it was more
real real because of that um
trajectory that you're describing in
comedy applies to television in general
you know i think about if you go back to
the if you showed
just to even if you showed an episode of
modern family which is still very
heightened
you know but if you go back and you show
that to someone from the 1950s
and you removed the shock of technology
and
culture and you just made it about the
like the way they were acting
by the way i think that's the one of the
such
one division so it's a ballsy move what
they did and like i told you i think
that
the at going back and watching it just
to appreciate the acting
and how they acted within the different
eras was
pretty brilliant and especially uh but i
don't know how who's the supporting act
actor in that the the who plays the
her friend agatha yeah who plays agatha
catherine whatever news
uh she does that
perfectly she embodies that those those
stereo
i mean elizabeth olsen is great in it
but
catherine what's her name is perfect in
the way that she's able to
embody those different tropes but yeah i
think we're getting
i mean if you you continue to the
trajectory and there's so many comedies
now
that are their dramedies
you know and it's so it's just
that resonates so much with us where you
can put funny people
in in in in real situations and
you can have it all you can have you can
have comedy and and all those things
right um
now what oh i mean that's i mean i think
we've
i don't know if we've if we've learned
anything established anything or if
you've
if you've gotten anything from this it
was a fun conversation though yeah
thanks for having it thanks for being
here
um and i can close with a wreck that
i've already anything that i talked
about
is is a wreck but i will say
that if you want like a 45 minute
uninterrupted just sit back
enjoy it experience
just google vic berger presents
jim the very best of jim baker and
it is it's just delightful
to me check it out
hashtag your biscuits let us know uh
what you
what you thought about this conversation
and um you know where you go for laughs
especially if you come to us for laughs
i'm interested in the other places
that you go yeah what's the what's the
venn diagram in your life the comedy
venn diagram
we'll talk at you next week to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best